I have a related question so the
technologies that you've developed
throughout your career have changed the
lives of millions of people for the
better hopefully and so I think it would
be you know probably possibly easy for
you to just sort of say well that's my
contribution you've also chosen to give
philanthropic Lee in a variety of ways
as well and I guess I'm just wondering
do you feel it was that a choice of
yours do you think that's sort of an
obligation that you know binds someone
else as well like is can your career be
the sole extent of your flat appeared as
a goatee deeper than that well I guess
um I think your career is an important
part of your giving back I think not
just making devices that change people's
lives and make their worlds better but
also building an ethical responsible
company that contributes to a community
that's that's taking care of its
suppliers and its employees and
everybody in the whole ecosystem I mean
I really see a company as as an ethical
entity too and that it needs to be able
to balance the needs of multiple
constituencies I mean you might want to
raise prices but that might you know
impact your investors positively but
your customers negatively so these are
always a balancing act of how do you
manage these things together and I think
thinking that through and understanding
I mean your ecosystem touches so many
people I mean I had however many
thousand employees we had in the company
but we were touching the lives of mass
multiples of that all the way down
through the supply chain anybody in
China who made the display who then
shipped it through a trucking company
and then so on and so forth so so I
think that needs to be an ethical system
and you need to think about that from
that perspective but in addition to that
so then you have this money that you
make as a result which I think for some
people it's a scorecard and they want to
hang on to it because they don't they
think they're losing score they're
losing points if they give it away but
for me it's really a way to make an
impact in other ways and for me it's
just a treasure to be able to use it in
that way I mean I spend it on myself to
I have thing
enjoy but but I really love to have the
opportunity to make a difference in the
world in other ways in addition to the
ways that I've made a difference in the
company